yes he's very content he went in and
joined EU 2007 ambassador's this morning
they were in there for a very short
period and then Donald just the
president of European Council
tweeted to say that they had agreed to
give the UK and extension I'll read you
the tweet Donald has said the eu-27 has
agreed that it will accept the UK's
request for a bet practical extension
until the 31st of January 2020 the
decision is expected to be formalized
through a written procedure now the
reason Donald Tusk is calling that flex
tension is that the extension would bow
to January the 31st
unless ratification of the deal is a
agreed before then and then the UK can
leave earlier it hasn't the UK has now
until the 31st of January if it leads to
you Donald 2 saying in that tweet that
if the agreement will be formalized or
extension will be formalized in written
procedure what he didn't want
Adam was to have to get all the 27 EU
heads back here to Brussels for another
summit they wanted to do it in writing
that will be now the procedure so we
understand that the French had held out
for quite some time president Mac ROM
wasn't very happy with the idea of a
long extension 3 months but he was
persuaded to come on board and they did
need to have a unanimous decision
they now have it there is speculation
that president and macron was moved
because he thought the idea and the
possibility of an election in Britain
was imminent and he'd always said all
along you're not just getting more time
for no good reason there has to be a
very specific reason and that reason
could be an election so there is
agreement for the so-called flex tension
until the 31st of January unless the UK
ratifies the deal before then and then
it can leave the EU earlier